hello everyone and welcome back to the
semifinals of the feeder Grand Prix it's
a young treat of Duda vs. Daniel dubov
and two of them are battling it out to
see who will face Alexander group in the
finals of the feeder Grand Prix
so two of the classical games between
the two of them have been run and this
is the first game of the rapid section
so the slower one the 30 minutes rapid
section and well it's a very interesting
game for a lot of reasons so I do hope
you enjoy it without further ado do that
opens with E 4 we have c5 the Sicilian
defense by Dube of Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 and we have d4c captures Knight
captures and here we have e 5 just
pushing the knight back going into the
the Alaska Pelican variation I'd be 5
and here d6 with Knight to c3
now a6 pushing the knight back Knight to
the a3 and now the most common move here
is b5 which procures b4 also keeps an ax
and C 4 square so the knight cannot
re-enter the game that easily but dubov
always goes for a4 sidelines so even in
this game Bishop to e6 so as he didn't
go for b5 do that takes this opportunity
to immediately and get the knight back
to back into the game from the the edge
of the board with Knight c4 and now rook
to b8 again preparing to push b5 so a
for preventing b5 with Knight to f6 by
dubov and Bishop to g5 continuing
development and night the b4 now putting
pressure on the under C 2 1 so you have
to be careful where do you develop your
Queen also if maybe the road goes to c8
you will you will have some trouble
moving the Knights as the the sea dew
point will be under attack
a5 taking fukken full control of the b6
square now the knight can even come to
b6 if needed and now comes d5 as we
always say if you play the silient and
you can put d5 you should always put d5
with each capture son d5 Knight B take a
cap captures on d5 and now another trade
on d5 Knight captures Queen captures and
here Bishop captures on f6 and it's
interesting Bishop captures on f6 is a
new move in the position the position
has been reached this year in
in the women's individual European
Championship between marina Bernal and
Olga gilja the game ended very abruptly
from this position because white played
Queen - II - which is which is a huge
mistake because Knights the e4 was
played and now well your Bishop is under
attack here it's just a tough position
if you move the brush back Bishop to c5
comes with a double attack on the f2
pawn so here
white played the rook to d1 but it's
just just a blunder of a piece well here
what what would happen is just Queen
captures on c4 and black of course one
because if Queen captures Queen captures
you get Bishop captures Bishop captures
black just ends up a piece so the
position has been reached before
although it really ended abruptly but
Bishop capture Sun on f6 is a new move
by Duda so as we move 14 we have a
completely new game with gcapp force on
f6 and now Queen captures on d5 Bishop
characters and a queenside castle for
Duda attacking the bishop on d5 better
back to c6 and now Knight to d6 with
check with Bishop captures rook captures
and now King to e7 pushing the rook back
preparing to bring the other Brooke into
the game and rook back to d3 by Judah
while route back to d3 and not d1 or d2
why block the development of your light
square bishop I have no good explanation
here maybe there were some ideas of
bringing the rook somewhere along the
3rd rank but we will never know
so rook beat d8 countering do this rook
on the D file and now rook the g1
preparing to develop the bishop or or if
rook captures then the bishop can
capture so the pawn on g2 is protected
with f5 and now g3
not making the g2 pawn a target anymore
and now King to f6 and here Duda takes
this opportunity to play Bishop to e2
it's not the greatest square for the
bishop but it's it's not a terrible
square for the bishop here we have rook
captures and d3 Bishop captures and now
efore with Bishop to c4 so you might you
might ask ourselves why did Du Bois
allow this or why didn't he just leave
the rook on d3 the bishop on e - what if
he allowed such
to square because now his King cannot
enter the game because the f7 point is
hanging well that's exactly the reason
why he did it here dubov decides that he
will give up the double f7 pawn to gain
more activity with the king and it and
it definitely is the correct idea here
Bishop captures an f7 by Judah and now
rook to f8 pushing the bishop back
Bishop to c4 and now f4 trying to create
more weaknesses and on the Queen so a
king side for Duda and if captures
captures then he also gets this very
active position for his King if if this
is allowed then black would be very
strong or even root captures on f4 which
comes with the immediate threat you can
threaten DF upon the h2 pond end and so
on but ok after f4 we have looked back
to f1 now with the idea that if if a
trade happens then you can just capture
with the H cone and this doesn't work
because the bishop already guards the
rook on f1 so you can just grab the pawn
back so after rook to f1 we have looked
to f6 now going for troop to h6 to
threaten the H to pawn we have B 3 and
now rook to h6 with h4 not allowing the
capture captures captures and the now
rode back to g6 pressuring the g3 pawn
and now rook the g1 pushing the rook
into into somewhat of a passive position
and now III and this is just a wonderful
idea with III you release the bishop you
also prevent king d2 which is a very
important active move for white and you
also clear the e4 square if needed for
the white king so g4 are grabbing more
space on the King side and now Bishop to
f3 not allowing King D to but now also
not allowing King to d1 the white king
will have some problems entering the
game game now we have g5 it's well you
do get to keep your point but you have
to advance them even further whereas the
blacks gains even more activity with his
King we have Bishop to d3
pressuring the rook and rook back to g7
and now b4 and okay rook back to d7 and
here we have rook to e1 not allowing the
King to enter even deeper because the
rook captures on e3 so for the moment
the
stuck on f4 we have looked east seven
and now the king can go to g3 to @f to
if needed because the brook is now
garden III pond and don't look back to
g1 we have looked back to d7 and he
looked he one do the repeats as well
even though he's up upon he would very
much enjoy a draw here because it's
dubov who's pushing in this position but
with russia back to h5 and here what do
you do here it's a very very tough
position for Duda as he's very long time
probably best as king be to try to get
the king into the game this way but he
decided to play b5 take care of business
on the Queen side so he only has the the
King side in the center of the board to
worry about but it comes with a captures
Bishop captures and rook to d5 now
pressuring the bishop after the bishop
moves you will recapture on a5 so Luke
the f1 with Chuck King to g3 and now
Bishop back to d3 but now you grab the
a5 on and here at the end of the day
it's three points each now so do go
equalized in material but he regains a
much more active position he already has
a passed pawn on e3 a White has no
passports and he has a very active King
and g3 so rook to f6 trying to create
some threats well trying to pick up some
of the pawns if possible but rooked 'if
i've now dubov now prepares upon to e2
and point 2 e 1 which is game over if
it's allowed for the moment it's not
possible but you know if white isn't
careful we've looked the b6 just going
after the b7 pawn and now comes looked
East 7 if you if you put the pawn right
away it doesn't do all that much even
though it seems like you can do it but
just Bishop captures and you you kind of
will be able to to hold on for example
Bishop captures and Bishop captures now
rook captures on b7 you're gonna
eliminate this pawn as well and you have
to two points here which you can push so
it's gonna be very hard to actually win
this with black but okay after work the
b6 dubov is in no rush he just goes
rogue back to e7
keeps an eye on all of the pawns and
v7 on h7 on e3 and here we have rook to
h6 if you don't if you don't do anything
then then e2 will be a very strong move
now because there will be no pawn
capturing along the seventh rank this
roof is not about to become a pig so
look the h6 now if you move the pawn
well you can just capture it and still
maybe push h5 create a passport with the
g6 it's it's possible that black and
maybe hold this sorry the white can
maybe hold this but Bishop to g6 of
course not allowing that if the up to g4
then again you get h5 and g6 even though
if e to you will still just give up that
point maybe put g6 and try to hold this
but Du Bois is in no rush to push any
points he just plays Bishop to g6
basically trapping the rook and now King
to d1 not allowing e2 now there is no
Bishop on h5 to guard the e2 square but
here we have kinked f2 so what do you
play here do that's right h5 he wants to
push push away this Bishop maybe even
trade some pieces maybe maybe try to
create some kinds of chances but feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the absolute best winning more for
do both while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations and
finding such a such an absolute best
winning move in in a winning endgame and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
a show its rook to d7
pin the bishop and now e to check is a
threat because the bishop will not be
able to capture the pawn so do the
cannot allow this he played King to c1
but now rook captures on d3 and now
everything goes you've eliminated the
defender of D 2 square it's not a
problem
white will no longer be able to
sacrifice the bishop for afor the pawn
see capture some d3 was played and e2
with H captures and g6 by Duda and now E
one check promoting to a queen king - C
- and now before recapturing and g6
dubov takes his time and perfectly
positions the Queen Queen to e2
with trick with King to c3 now Queen to
e5 with check d4 and now Queen to c7
with check
King today - and only now H captors and
g6 and it was in this position that
youngsters to do that resign the game as
he can't even capture the g6 pawn and
try to maybe hold on because here just
if you capture a twenty five check
results in white losing the role because
the black ink creates a wall here you
have to go back if you go here and then
just Queen to a5 check picks up the rook
as you will be in check and if you play
something like this then just Queen c3
check and it doesn't matter where you go
Queen to d3 check will again pick up the
rook so after this
well not that but after hCAP force and
g6 youngstreet of do the resigns and do
both takes the lead one to zero in the
rapid time section so next game Duda has
the black pieces and he's in a must-win
situation we'll see how it goes for
those of you who are watching live you
already know how it went but for those
of you who are now you know you can
either just check yourselves or wait for
me to upload the next one so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Pavan Karim Shetty for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the saga of the
feeder Grand Prix 2019 I've continued to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and and so on so thank you all I will
see soon and have an excellent rest of
your day